[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
steve crowder is
a gross person i mean
steven crowder i mean
this is what you can expect from trash
like youtube dragged his feet before
taking any action against conservative
commentator stephen crowder
who is that stephen crowder stephen
crowder is youtube's ideal creator he
makes cheap long content that tons of
people watching subscribe voices are
really funny so congrats on that you
know what you can do with your copyright
strikes
and if you ain't mad enough to do it
yourself
i'd be happy to oblige
everybody's tweeting at me i really
would going on their shows and said
all kinds of things
but i don't mind
from where i am the sun is shining
here to entertain
anyone who don't like it
can get born
[Music]
hey
you stephen crowder
from where i am the sun is shining
here to entertain
anyone
can get born
[Music]
hey if you a stephen crowder
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hmm
yeah wonderful yeah oh my headphones
coming a little hot hey senator uh
hirono uh it's uh this content may be
long it's not cheap
that's what you pick the fight with yeah
really do you have any idea how surreal
it is to have members of the united
states government calling for your
removal from a social media platform
does she count i don't know if she
counts i mean come on what is she yeah
hawaii or something i don't know i don't
know something about that is a fun quick
way to japan i don't know exactly but
hey look we have a lot to get to today
we'll be talking about obviously uh
former vice president joe biden and
peter ducey uh hilarious
the deuce yes
self given nickname yes don't you always
hate it when people give themselves
nicknames like i am the red warrior who
came up with that i i just did do you
like it i love it t-bone t-bone
i still would like to be called thick
o'malley well that's fine that's why we
do it
[Laughter]
um one thing i will say too we'll be
talking about we mentioned this
yesterday and people said hey you know
what we'd like to see a more in-depth
segment on this
uh
the world and how they view the united
states versus
today versus under president donald
trump remember when they always used to
say hey our world isn't respected
anymore under president donald trump
with a laughingstock well let's compare
how the world actually interacted with
the united states under president trump
specifically right now we're dealing
with you know foreign threats with
russia ukraine uh but also china north
korea our international standing our
economy i think it's important i think
this is we live in a culture now and
this is kind of canceled culture people
talk about and i don't use that term a
whole lot but we do live in a culture
and this is the byproduct of feminism
for sure where words are often given
more credence than actions
and sure president donald trump said
some mean words sometimes he said words
i didn't even like but you have to look
at the actions not only of our leaders
but those who uh follow them what kind
of example they set how they inspire
people i think when you look at the
results
this is the one silver lining before i
get to anything else a silver lining
that we have in the united states today
if you right now watching listening do
your job
is we had eight years of barack obama
and former vice president joe biden
we had four we really had three years of
president donald trump
there's a contract and now we're going
to have another four years of former
vice president biden so you've got 12
years with four sandwich in the middle
and whether you like it or hate it
there's no denying that there is a
contrast and if you do your job that
contrast will serve to continue creating
momentum with
more black republican voters than ever
before more black latino voters than
ever before more conservative young
voters than ever before issues second
amendment first amendment issues if you
do your job there is a real value here
in eight four and four so we'll be
talking about that today also since
we're going to be talking about that if
this show gets booted on the youtube you
can watch us on mug club we do an extra
full hour on mug club we do an extra
hour uh every day monday through
thursday or rumble 10 a.m eastern
lately it's been closer to 10 30 because
news breaks in the morning well you guys
like a little bit later start let us
know let us know if you like it yeah
we're thinking about starting later
because people in specific are you know
they're like oh so early i have to sleep
uh and my question for you today
i'm trying to think if this will require
that you immediately switch over to
rumble or mug club
does former vice president biden have
dementia do you think so i know i'm not
a doctor yes neither are you sorry yeah
no he's he was confirming that you're
not a doctor right oh yes yes that's
what i meant also not a doctor am i the
only one i am who likes women in
turtlenecks
yes i don't know why i just find turtle
a woman in a church we'll explain it
because jen saki ruined it for everybody
we'll get to it i love that turtleneck
cleavage also uh well that's the whole
point is he can't cheat a turtleneck
well yeah it's just the way god made you
i don't want a girl look like a sprocket
well i don't i'm not saying she has to
look like deiter nobody should wear
turtlenecks and that except robert now's
the time on sprockets very take press
conference and say stupid son of a [ __ ]
all right gerald a is with us how are
you sir i am well sir i do have to
admonish you off the top you did say
black latino republicans i caught that
as well that is that is what did i say i
said black voters and i said latino
voters exactly said black and then black
latino and i'm like well that's an
interesting mexican well they do exist
thank you
don't you admonish yourself listen
if i don't do it somebody else will do
it and i
i care okay they don't live in fern
gully it's totally acceptable you said
that hey isn't that where robin williams
also did another voice over he might
have it's a magical hey look i do a
genie now i'm uh look now i'm a pat hey
look bad old man ho ho ferngally big oil
there you go oil slick oh boy this is
intense
who's the funny guy oh i'm very sad
right now oh i'm sad but i put on a
clown face oh ho cocaine
uh and you've heard his voice already
but i guess i'll uh do the honors of
introducing he will be at the cuyahoga
cuyahoga falls funny stuff in ohio
cuyahoga ohio funny stop uh this weekend
dave landau how are you ahoy i'm good
yourself i'm doing well i'm glad you
woke up today
this guy tells me to get an iphone
because he likes the texting better than
blames me no no the reason that we said
you need to get an iphone is because
half the time you'll be like oh i didn't
get your text and yours was oh you know
i want android all right control okay i
thought it was still 20 22 where you are
apparently i've had a blackberry yes
aren't i stuck with it yes
stock i've lost he woke up in ghana
that's why uh yeah i woke up on
somebody's front lawn dressed as a
vagina yeah well look we've all been
there i know right that's why your new
nickname it was your lawn it's a man who
wakes up in lawn dressed as a vagina
that's my favorite thing that caesar
milan ever said and by the way we have
crowder 911 coming up here later this
week or next week he said even when i
was young i was uh i was known as i was
a mexican guy who could still walk a
pack of rottweilers that's why they used
to call me the mexican guy who can walk
a pack of wine
that was his next name
that is amazing i never heard him say
that oh i do like him all right before
we go on anything else i guess we have
to watch this and react um really i
haven't watched this i've been
instructed not to until so i get to
experience it with you on air together
yeah the people
apparently the coveted tick tocks are
getting out of control and cringy let's
see what's going on i guess i'm still
like a mystery it's like who is she i
certainly don't know i'll tell you this
much i'm not picky i'll still ravage you
if you've been with alpha or delta
you're not gonna ravage anyone delta
you're just jealous because i am getting
more attention you're popular you're not
serious i kept people quarantined for 10
days i drove them insane tell me about
it i can be very serious um could you
just expand upon that for a second
case in point what the cdc makes
everyone laugh not everyone all the
vaccines tie me down and none of them
can get me okay yes the vaccines made me
feel vulnerable because i feel like they
really understood me but i didn't fall
for them as bad as myself am i late
alpha stop trying to look cool we all
know you were the first one here i
actually did not know that guys come on
i know i'm not around as much anymore
but did you forget who trailblazed this
path for you honestly yes that's how
long ago you were relevant ew don't
compare us i'm evolved we're different
dress is falling that is so many ways hi
um i'm delta kron i'm new here what what
who somebody say my name okay look i
know that i've
said that university is mostly go to
film school can i quit life go to film
school go to film school if only to
learn that's that's circa 2009 youtube
type vlogging which i used to do with
the blue bed sheet behind me if you're
doing a voice to a k
look left then switch and look right
they don't understand the line of action
i just
why did we give everybody a tv show i
well you know that's all the internet
did it just handed everybody a show and
then telling us who the idiots are well
the beauty is there used to be no
gatekeepers but now they just these
these people just they need to lock
themselves in a gate
i don't even know walls work
she was supposed to be eminem right at
one point and i don't fully understand i
do understand that she is someone who
obviously was not uh was not uh
talented uh fetching enough to make it
in the you know purely fetching realm so
but also not funny enough to do uh
anything yeah she should be getting
crapped out of the bottom of the porn
industry ouch what that should be but
that once upon a time
i'm just saying how life should work
jared it'll grow up i don't know that
you're the real world extra in the porn
industry dave well you know
the people on the couch watching yeah it
looks like they
didn't and they're like why is this
happening
person fully clothed oh and by the way
they pay scale oh
so you let it never be said that the
unions didn't give you anything uh by
the way you can follow us on tick tock
even though the chai comes have banded
us what have they banned us now uh like
three times yeah thrice
but
the show came back the very next day
okay like a bad virus speaking of
everyone getting their show who do you
think we're gonna be talking about next
child oh
who are we gonna talk about next sure
it's the one who ran on the lamb as a
nun
child
yesterday on the view
[Laughter]
she was incredibly
uh upset
karina karina uh
is that ray liotta
it's a terrible movie it's a miracle he
didn't punch her while filming that i'm
sure he did
he wasn't back then before chantix so
they both
you know ironically she
the the daughter gets him to quit
smoking in that movie
didn't use change
whoops
oh that's brilliant so okay all right
that'll be an open at some point soon so
yesterday on the view whoopi goldberg
was really mad about uh you know uh bill
maher and um
she also think talked about barry weiss
there but she was really mad about bill
maher discussing the actual science and
of course what ends up happening is you
know this is the same thing they always
do what if it saves one life okay how
many millions have been uh have been
exterminated in the abortion holocaust
but here's the thing joe uh not joe
biden will be golden yeah just
old people who fart how did you do this
it wasn't it was a me cushion
what is this ghost i don't see color
child i don't see color child i see
patrick swayze and to me more getting
action on pottery and i was just paid as
an extra to watch that's right i will
follow him wherever he may go come on
now joy behar's not jewish but she wants
you to think she is she's a she's an
italian child yeah she's got a big old
elf nose
all right
let's try this again all right yesterday
whoopi goldberg was very upset that bill
maher was discussing the science tried
to browbeat him but there's a feridian
slip here let's see if you can catch it
take a look
i don't want to live in your paranoid
world anymore your masked paranoid world
you know you go out it's silly now you
know you have your mask you have to have
a card you have to have a booster they
scan your head
like you're a
cashier and i'm a bunch of bananas
i'm not bananas you are yes that's
not really funny to people who have lost
their kids
to this vaccine or people who've lost
family members or
dear friends to this it's it's just you
know listen nobody on the planet really
wants to go through this this is not
something we're doing because it's you
know sexually gratifying whatever
sexually gratifying to you is the stuff
of children's nightmares what uh where's
the rest of the parliament funkadelic
but did you catch what she said yeah
that's really funny to people who've
lost their kids
to this vaccine
oh
lost their kids to the vaccine
now i know probably just you know she
misspoke but uh hey uh
youtube are you gonna you know the view
channel or are you gonna take them down
for covet misinformation do we know
tokenellon are they still up
oh a token why is everything uh why is
everything uh uh blurred there the
channel i don't know i guess that's the
action they took it's the sexual
gratification like you gotta blur the
sexual stuff uh i think it's just
because it's gross yeah yeah it's hard
to look at now here's what's funny about
this too not only did whoopi goldberg
say that but uh the clip and you can
find the clip on their channel the clip
though that you just saw was pulled from
a more left-leaning twitter account and
this is what they tweeted out it says
it's a quote that's not really funny to
people who've lost
ellipses family members or dear friends
ellipses this is not something we're
doing because it's sexually gratifying
they lost who to what who what when
where why that's the first rule right
took out the stuff that they took out of
it they took out lost to the vaccine
isn't it true i mean bill maher like him
or not and please get lasik but like him
or not like there's no reason he's being
glasses you don't just do glasses
not you're fine you had glasses already
okay that's a cheap shot yeah come on
okay
dave
talk about mine lasik this guy's sitting
in the leather very tall thank you it's
a good thing you're not but i'm not
bananas you're bananas look at it
um
but it shows that that this guy who is
extremely far left is now being almost
looked at as alt-right like they really
have pushed him into this realm yeah it
just shows how absolutely insane the
left has got including the view i'm not
saying you're insane you're bananas
you're insane in the membrane you're a
juggler yeah well i take shanks ray i
specifically hate how she starts with
kids as if she's trying to pull on like
heart strings and i went back and look
just to confirm the cdc's careful
careful just to confirm careful i'm just
going to say numbers okay there's like
700 kids who have died in the last two
years from cove that's 700 too many it
is that's 700 childs i agree i have too
many child i have a young son and that's
zero to children 17 years old that's
happened like four times in the last 10
years you haven't been four times that's
more than children of the corn that's a
lot of child they're crucified
and that doesn't mean it's okay i'm just
saying was whoopi out there saying the
same things about that don't bury your
cat it'll come back not be the same oh
my goodness yeah no i do want to thank
you you're making a good pack no the cat
always comes back yeah
yeah you can't kill them come on yeah
i'm like that it's not like a scary
movie i had a career in film i had a
career then in a one-woman show that no
one wanted to see so now i've been i am
permanently glued to this seat
in the view when i get up the seat
follows my ass i wonder who watches that
show i really do all the child who are
who are raised by the tv in the middle
of the day it's either us or the price
is right and they'd rather have the
child watch our children
want to watch color purple no no jumping
jack flash no no no i made some crap all
right
speaking of crap here's uh
another sake bomb
yesterday
claimed that we can't judge here's the
thing and i want to preface this
none of us here judge the economy by the
stock market foreshadowing but she
answered and she was irritated because
they're irritated anytime they're
challenged because they're used to going
completely unchallenged that's what the
left sees as the status quo and that's
why you are seeing very different you
can't blame donald trump and kelly
mcinerney
you can't blame them
for being more confrontational when you
had the media essentially accusing them
of lies they're still doing it today
they're still doing it today more with
president they attack president biden
more than they attack
current vice former vice president joe
they they attacked donald trump more
than they attack former i just have to
former vice president biden who for some
reason is giving press conferences today
i have no idea why
usually former vice presidents don't do
that so yesterday uh saki claimed that
we can't judge biden's economy by the
stock market
go ahead thanks first on the markets
does the president think it's a big deal
that today the dow jones is down
at one point more than 1100 points
that's a lot of points to start with we
focus on the trends in the economy not
any one day and any single indicator
unlike his predecessor the president
does not look at the stock market as a
means by which to judge the economy i
would note
that the market is up around 15 percent
compared to when president biden took
office
but our measure of success is really how
real working families are doing whether
they have a little breathing room
whether they have a job that delivers
some dignity in a paycheck that can
support they can support a family on and
we've seen a great deal of progress made
on that front okay couple things she
ruined turtlenecks for me i love women
in turtlenecks i don't know is it me
comment below guys out there yes i like
women you know what i just feel like
it's it's just uh
it's it's like uh you know having to in
other words you can't set a swimming
record today yeah if you're wearing that
uh whatever it is that's a flight suit
that makes you swim faster you know what
i mean they banned it from the olympics
or something did they ban it i don't
know the point is it's not the same it's
an even playing field if all women are
internal necks
okay
and so then you can just see like that's
a beautiful woman because okay here's my
point put
whoopi goldberg in a turtleneck huh
right
okay why have to use a tarp then put
anyone attractive put kate upton put
adele in a turtleneck okay there's it
just makes the contrast that more that
much more i just like turtlenecks come
on come on
she's very attractive yes and a
turtleneck some women can pull it off
that's what i'm saying the women who can
pull off turtlenecks can pull off
anything again robert wagner only man
that can pull off of a turtleneck that's
true oh my god and push a lady off a
boat and kill natalie wood
i don't know did you notice to what she
just did she said you know we don't use
unlike our predecessor we don't use a
stock market as an indicator and then
she and then she again it's a sleight of
hand says we should note that it's up to
one percent more than one percent here's
the thing the stock market always goes
up right 15 cents he took office since
that was she said 15 since he took
office uh what was the one percent
number she was discussing i don't
remember that i don't remember that but
she immediately points to the number of
the stock market yeah
which is the worst indicator in relation
to right previous administration this
because it will always go up it's it's a
matter of to what degree it went up if
you buy the market you rebalance you win
that's the idea of building equity over
to building wealth over time through
equities right you don't pick stocks
monkey with a with a dart board does it
more effectively than the most effective
hedge funds in the world but the stock
market always goes up so she points to
that and then says but that's not our
only management okay you know what let's
not just use the stock market how about
we use numbers like uh unemployment
under president donald trump 3.5 that
was the lowest since 1969. let's compare
that to president joe biden 3.9
unemployment which by the way is also
with a very low a cripplingly low labor
force participation there's about 3
million americans not in the job market
right now that were yes donald trump
here's the thing they will say look our
economy is bouncing back
sure okay you can say that your economy
is bouncing back from the worst low
point since you know china released this
uh plague upon the world sorry
accidentally exactly yeah so you can say
sure we're better than we were uh in
2020 when we all demanded that the
economy be shut down and then once we uh
you know uh in the most free and fair
election never
took office decided to open it back up
kind of
however the high water mark was 2019.
the high water mark was 2019. how many
jobs have been added since the economy
that existed under donald trump
pre-covered
anyone want to guess
i would say what in the negative because
collapsing at the economy so people lose
a bunch of jobs and then adding i don't
know 12 more is not a good thing exactly
it's stupid so the actual amount of jobs
added since the high water mark of 2019
is
zero but don't take my word for it here
are the experts on cnbc you're either
not going to see wage gains or you
actually see a reversal is that even
possible never that
well it's possible especially if you're
talking about real wages which are
negative if you look at these cpi
numbers what i'm concerned about is that
yes we've seen wage increases but we've
seen wage increases driven by labor
shortages the economy and this is an
important point hasn't added one single
job from the 2019 high watermark not one
all the jobs that we have seen gained
are recovered jobs that were lost we are
not yet producing new jobs in fact we're
still about nearly four million jobs
short so these wage gains are coming on
top of a shrinking workforce and it's
not being fueled by productivity
enhancement now here's the thing if we
wanted to find common ground i would
agree
with jen saki and that it shouldn't be
the only indicator that we use however
it's the only indicator that the buy
administration can use for any sort of
success and it just so happens to be the
indicator that consistently goes up
regardless of who is in office over
time long run yeah absolutely and here's
the thing donald trump wasn't hanging
his hat on the stock market what he was
doing is making life better for every
american and going and the stock market
exactly well by the way your retirement
your 401k that's tied to this number hey
that's good right and this is why again
remember i said the benefit of contrast
four right sorry eight under obama four
under donald trump and now we're gonna
have four under uh former former vice
president joe biden here's the value uh
in that contract right you can point to
these examples you can point it's
concrete it's quantifiable right this is
the same thing here when we're talking
about uh not only the stock market but
we're talking about the disconnect
between americans and their everyday
lives their employment opportunities
versus the stock market they were
congruent under donald trump people were
doing better wages went up an average of
i think the average wage went up about
five thousand dollars in the first three
years under barack obama was 1 000 under
eight years so wages went up and the
stock market was doing well right now
you have home prices
skyrocketing and you have the stock
market going up but you don't have
any jobs being added and you're saying
some jobs no zero jobs negative four
million jobs we're still missing four
million jobs but the stock market is
still going up and home prices are still
going up that's the disconnect that's
what's dangerous now the only silver
lining and i don't want this to happen
at the expense of americans
unfortunately it already is
is that you can have this conversation
right now at home
with your family with your friends they
know what they're experiencing
they can see the disconnect you just
need to point it out for them yeah and i
think one of the other points too is
that wages went up what 4.1 percent
they're like oh biden is great four
point one seven percent inflation do you
know that wages could go up a hundred
percent that actually means that wages
have decreased about 2.8
down in your buying power right
that's insane i remember that when i
looked at my ira several years ago and
trump was in office i was like wow
that's quite an increase and they were
like yeah thank trump and now the very
same guy is like brace for impact right
my r.a just bombed a church
a different ira
so uh speaking of uh former vice
president joe biden uh yesterday and
this is the one that everyone is talking
about of course we do have some
exclusive information here uh yesterday
biden was caught in a hot mic
and i say caught let me be really clear
here whether you guys like dick cheney
or not okay and i'm not going to voice
any opinions on dick cheney i think
there was a lot of bad but i think it's
pretty hard to argue that dick cheney
was anything but smart the guy was a
clever man yeah he didn't say he was
clever and evil if you don't like him
but you can't just paint him as the dumb
republican right that's what people did
with george w bush he was president for
eight years effectively
like cheney like kamala
so
there was a moment though where he
leaned into i believe it was john
edwards microphone when john edwards
brought up his lesbian daughter i think
it was at a debate and he said
you can go f yourself for bringing up my
daughter he knew where the mic was that
wasn't a hot mic moment no that was a
bend over and spank moment this is a man
who again you can come in if you think
he has dementia or alzheimer's whatever
uh neurodegenerative disease you think
you know what i'm maybe picky i'm asking
if people do i'm not making a claim yeah
yeah i agree not like the view with
deaths from vaccines it's true
their words not ours yesterday former
vice president joe biden was caught in a
hot mic
completely unaware
but you know i mean i do i need to add
that part uh after an exchange with
reporters and here's what he said about
peter ducey
[Music]
that's a great asset
more inflation
what a stupid sound [ __ ]
[Music]
nicest at least we have nice back in the
white house remember he does know that
there's a microphone in front of him and
he's at a podium right with a red light
on a camera
and a room full of reporters
come on i know it was a hot mic but i
didn't realize
what else could it be and he was saying
it as though he was saying it under his
breath like no one knows where he goes
dumb son of a [ __ ] oh i got all of that
one
so satisfied with himself like when a
kid makes a poop also made a poop by the
way admitting to in the horrible
inflation right before
i know
it couldn't be worse
it absolutely couldn't be worse remember
when people were saying oh donald trump
was mean at least joe biden's nice
here's the thing at least at least
donald trump would be like hey hey you
hey yo look at me look at me you're a
dubstep of a [ __ ]
your parents should be ashamed and look
when i say that don't take it out of
context i mean your mother is a [ __ ] oh
wow and you're a [ __ ] you come from a
line of [ __ ] i hope i've made myself
clear
i think so and this guy just tried he's
holding up three mics yes hold on a
second i think i have here oh look at
this giant hand that says
stephanopoulos is a [ __ ]
and this guy's just a stupid son of a
[ __ ] he's just like just he's he's a
piece he's he's a piece of [ __ ] i'm
sorry he also muttered it out of the
corner of his mouth by opening his mouth
as much as he could right
like the clown at mini putt yes well
it's hilarious to see the reaction to
this brian stelter i think in 2018
actually tweeted out that he was saying
that this is unfit for him as a
candidate when or not in 2018 but when
he was a candidate prior to being
elected in 2016 and then now as
president it's even worse and i'm just
like guys you're coming out in joe
biden's defense now saying yeah at least
he said it right i'm like nobody i
didn't care when trump said it the first
time and i don't care that biden said it
yeah
at least joe biden shoots straight from
his broken hip yeah so unity right there
but anybody who's the president is going
to have some level of egomania you know
what i mean like it's like the only
difference is trump just didn't care if
you saw it right yeah but ducey is
trying to bait him do see
something that was just like ah you jerk
and i'm glad he said what he said it's
funny to me because it's honest well
here's the thing then the reports have
been circulating that former vice
president joe biden called peter ducey
to apologize to him to do some damage
control here's the thing
we have uh we're the first ones to get
our hands on this um we actually have
the exclusive we have the call between
former vice president joe biden and fox
news's peter ducey hello you're in the
dew zone peter's speaking hello alan
it's former vice president joe my name
is peter i just said that right come on
i knew that
the thing
the mother president harris
and the fire crutch said i should
apologize
for calling you a dumb son of a
son of a bee it's all right joseph come
on craig we're friends
call me bruce that's
all the kids you know
call me who pet my leg here again my
name is peter and i'm not calling you
broseph oh
oh then
just call me every man joe i don't care
come on what'd you call me i don't care
but don't call me late for putting okay
then every man joe can i please start
getting real answers to my press
questions now that we're friends oh i
i'll take what's behind door number
three are you listening to me at all
come on listen brian
mother says i gotta go
i'm sorry mr putin i never should have
merged those calls is he sleeping
the world is laughing at us oh my gosh
it's real audio yeah i know look late
nights i don't know how we keep getting
it i don't know why they would send it
to you know a comedy show he does always
sleep though when he eats pudding he
does well look it's just you know it's
like when you have a coma after
thanksgiving something to do with
tryptophan and dementia now
alzheimer's here's something else here's
some drama going on neil young who neil
young stop it shut your face neil young
i had to look at me i don't like his
politics the guy's an amazing guitar
player the guy is a great musician but
he's also a dick neil young asks spotify
to remove his music due to quote false
information about vaccines and this is
neil young who was of course the other
part of crosby stills nash and young uh
and uh this was referring to joe rogan
he was mad that joe rogan was on spotify
saying this is a problem there's vaccine
misinformation i guess he's joining the
uh the troop of doctors and or people
who have phds in philosophy who want to
get rid of joe rogan and actually uh it
resulted with neil young finally putting
his foot down and saying
quote uh spotify you can either have joe
rogan or neil young joe rogan
immediately respond like okay spotify we
didn't even know you were still on here
we pick joe rogan i think they responded
at the or yeah
or done old man take a look at my wines
i'm a little [ __ ] yeah go over to apple
or one of the other reputable
corporations that's right i have a heart
of gold what's wrong with it no i have a
nasal coal are you what are you selling
and i'm getting old
have you getting a hold have you it's
the way my nose is that's how i talk
yeah you have neil young when i get yeah
what i got stuffed up have you tried
clear
it helps get rid of neil young nasal
troubles here ready nice
oh oh he caught it they're easy to catch
that's one good thing about clear
let's see if it works
uh uh aye
and i'm getting old try to do both
get no
hey guys just so you know uh go wash
your nose at home this is actually
sponsored the show i talked about it a
long time ago i've been using it for a
long time you brush your teeth you wash
your face
think of all the crap you're breathing
in you live in new york you're basically
inhaling everyone's coffee breath and
hobo farts and you don't clean out your
respiratory tract go to clear it's x
clear spelled with an x because the
ingredient is xylitol uh dot com you can
get it from amazon you can get it over
the counter and they have some studies
on this and covid yeah well uh that are
published by the way just so you know
i'm making no matter it's like real
studies like actual studies actual
trials and the beauty of this because it
cleans out your nasal passages and if
you want to wear a mask a vaccine
there's no reason not to use it it's
helped me remember how i said i'd rather
uh i'd rather be crucified upside down
than sneeze after my surgery yeah that's
helped a lot we tried a lot with my
tried to do it i got to tell you about a
month ago no joke i uh i had a sinus
infection because it turns out there's
still other diseases besides
and uh i you gave me that before they
were even a sponsor and it worked great
yeah i used it right before i went on
stage yeah yeah that was the whole
protocol that you had it's like hey
let's try to do something to help us
through this problem with covet and just
general like seasonal stuff but it was
funny because one of the guys was a fan
of the show and he's like oh
they just mentioned us on the show yeah
i know
and so they came out i'm like yeah yeah
like would you do you would you would
you like to tell people use their stuff
i'm like yeah use your stuff yeah what
are you talking about i already told him
i used your stuff how do you think you
know you're gonna give a sponsor i mean
i already did it for free so that's
what's wonderful about our sponsors as
they partner up with us it's great
honestly i get sick a lot less i use it
before every time i get on an airplane
yeah uh here's something else i also use
it anytime i go to the cnn green room
because stelter green it's a waft
what about he's got a stank yeah this is
the way i put it whenever stelter leaves
a room there's a green
stelter shaped cloud of where he used to
be yeah it's like yeah right chlorine
and feces
yeah like someone tried to rather than
actually cleaning the toilet bowl yeah
just spritz it with chlorine so it's a
mix yeah oh no kind of like the air
freshener in a cab where it just smells
like poop like somebody ate too much
cotton candy and vomited and then ate it
again yeah well that's because oh what
that's his lunch break yeah yeah that's
what he has to do with that he has he
asks to do his cotton candy breaks alone
yeah he's like i need to have cotton
candy until i'm very sick totally
straight so brian stelter yesterday
highlighted uh a school and these are
this is a wonderful site children in
masks teacher and masks and at one point
brian stelter made a visit but he did a
whole package at cnn highlighting a
school teaching young children
specifically not about covid
nor math no but about condoms on a
banana with his mouth how to identify
more specifically
misinformation
just imagine trying to make sense of all
of this as a teenager now we go to
imposter content what does imposter mean
try someone trying to be someone else
right you hear that word was an imposter
well let it never be sentenced
[Laughter]
and all those kids were like he is not
don't ever say i didn't do anything for
you yeah i love it make sure it says
hetero
i bet you he doesn't like broads and
turtlenecks
i don't think he likes and broads
they could be sans turtlenecks all right
he probably wants some of the he jobs
to go swimming in the dead sea
go take a slim wear the hijab this one's
double it's double layered for
insulation
put your head back oh no
i like the masks on women yes yes this
has been a good this has been a good two
years for me
i've enjoyed it it's easier to walk down
the street and see but
um
well not all butts i'm not ladies 50
of the bats man butt
no man bun and man totally straight
women these are two of my everyone knows
that i like women bots
stop it i love ladybugs you stop your
misinformation i just love i love big
breasts yes so sexy i just brian stelter
i just i just wanna i just wanna take
those big old
voluptuous breasts and put it in my
handbag and take them home with me
you're over selling guys
you're you're you're underselling what
you don't you just don't like breasts
and women as much as i do you just don't
appreciate it yeah you know
just big fat old a cup you know what i
really like
brian selter you know what i really like
what i like i really like i'm other
brothers you know what i like a lot
it's almost my favorite thing is sex
with women
okay one the angel on my shoulder says
boys but the devil says man
i know and you know what
i sometimes listen
it depends in the mood
so i'm going to put on some nelio oh man
take a look at my sack i wish
[Laughter]
all right harmony and i'm getting hot
[Music]
and dick's not getting old
he keeps singing with his
[ __ ] of gold
totally
i like boobs they're gold i like and i'm
really turned on
by their boobies
i i just like i like a nice vegetarian
i've thrown up twizzlers and starbursts
all over my desk
there's skills everywhere certainly
taste the rainbow oh there's just
skeletons you can fly the flag just
don't eat it
[Laughter]
you know you know the thing that's what
they that's what his part-time job is as
you know the cotton candy they scoop it
up they just hold stelter by the feet
yay
oh my god
totally i look like george costanza but
i love penis
allegedly and well no penis means
boobs
really
okay
so
this is also another question i have for
you by the way if you're watching on
youtube
speaking of ryan shelter smash that like
button like as an attractive woman in a
turtleneck
or a slab of cotton candy
[Laughter]
oh there you go everyone knows she-hulk
was my first love it was
and uh you can also look comment do you
think the world is more respected under
donald trump was more respected under
donald trump or under former vice
president biden this is a narrative that
goes around sort of like i didn't buy
into the narrative that uh barack obama
was all that smart i don't think he was
dumb right they made it sound like he
was a genius right right never bought
into that constitutional expert i
thought he was charismatic he's
charismatic very charismatic so we're a
lot of really flavorful history so was
bill clinton before he just went full
pervert well he was always full pervert
now he just looks like a guy who would
sit outside a like kid's foot locker
yeah
a map are you saying you know that's
inaccurate because i'm a dsw man
they don't have a kids dsw though they
don't know
i don't know my outlets
now um this is a narrative that i never
believed and i i will uh i'll make the
case here we are at a significant
deficit now with former vice president
joe biden uh at the semi-helm than we
were with donald trump and i think again
we have a couple of years now we had
four years really three under donald
trump let's be honest they robbed him of
that of that last year a little bit so
before we move on to the specifics uh as
far as international policy and and i
think these matter and we'll we'll try
and keep them brief for you because i
know your eyes glaze over certainly
daves do they glaze over like brian
stelter with the sports illustrated
swimsuit catalog yeah
boring no no he's like i love this yeah
this is wonderful someone get me cat
fancy
and a copy of cats yes
i eat it while i watch it
as we all know of course putin and
global leaders here uh they have no
respect for former vice president joe
biden don't take my word for it
i want to ask you did you order
the assassination of
the woman who walked into the congress
and who was shot and killed by a
policeman do you know that 450
individuals were arrested after entering
the congress and they didn't go there to
steal a laptop
they came with political
demands 450 people have been detained
they're facing they're looking they're
they're looking at jail time between 15
and 25 years and they came to the
congress with political demands isn't
that
prosecution for political opinions no i
don't like him but he makes a point a
very good point
he's right yeah
look at how he dismisses him here we
need a body language expert
and a calm
[Laughter]
shut up
for those watching yes i moved my chair
down i just wanted to see how it felt
down here
was just because we were looking at
biden from a position of weakness so i
always want to put myself in their shoes
now okay should move him back from the
table for those who are listening on
audio
table there yeah for those who are
listening there always is yeah he has he
has just glued to his uh it's part of
his writer for appearance he has a kid's
table that he can spin like the packages
in the full monty now that's true there
is a kid's table it's for prince andrew
yes
that that people are listening on audio
that was uh when they when that uh uh uh
a chinese official who was that exactly
was that uh that wasn't uh that was an
ambassador i believe i i don't i don't
have their exact name phony not all
ambassadors look alike that's not what
i'm saying oh jeez uh when he said so
you know the united states just elected
former vice president joe biden the
audience laughs yeah here's the beauty
of laughter it's an involuntary response
you can't control it and you know he
didn't have the bill maher uh laugh
applause side now
let's look at the difference between
donald trump and former vice president
biden and where we are in the world
standing here okay trump earned respect
because he refused to follow the really
this sort of global policy which i
addressed yesterday yesterday of of
liberal hegemony now some people are
saying it's liberal hegemony i don't
know i don't know i've never heard it
said that way but apparently that's the
proper way can we come up with another
word that doesn't sound stupid okay
globalist [ __ ] agenda there we go wait
what perfect
i like the global agenda where they're
making humanoid hybrids ah that one
liberal hedge hegemony hegemony
hegemony we should also cast a spell
spirit of sanctus and then you know
invisibility cloak eg money they're
working on it money okay
the global idea that uh you know what
we're all one and the same really it
comes down to this idea that the united
states is not only superior to other
countries and i don't just mean superior
because of uh some type of god-given
right that the lord blessed this country
what i mean is superior in the sense
that we have laws like the first
amendment the second amendment we have
laws that enshrine basic rights that are
not granted by government but recognized
by government no one else does this so
liberals don't want to the left doesn't
want to acknowledge the superiority of
the united states because they want us
all to be the same that's why you can't
have borders what would you need borders
for well you typically need borders
to make sure that you have quality
control to make sure that a country that
provides and affords opportunities that
no other country ever in the history of
the world has is able to maintain that
do away with the borders do away with
the borders do it with the opportunities
and let's create a dependent state so
donald trump did not follow this policy
a doctrine if you want to call it now
let's look at what donald trump did
internationally
left the paris climate of court
the uh iran nuclear deal he cut some un
funding which i love oh yeah he skipped
u.n summits on climate change and covid
he replaced nafta with the usmca he
renegotiated nato in 2016 only four of
29 nato allies were contributing what
they agreed upon
the two percent of their national gdp
into nato uh by 2020 that number had
increased to 10. just to be clear donald
trump said people weren't paying their
fair share and nato is of no value to
the united states if we're funding the
security for the rest of the world
that's a total first off that's a
totally valid point of view to have
okay it's a valid point of view to have
also you should negotiate from a place
of power if you're the greatest country
in the world and the greatest military
superpower in the world also they're not
honoring their word the other nato
allies so you may not like that it's
abrasive but it is absolutely the right
thing to do yeah you know what happens
when russia invades i don't know estonia
to us
nothing so pay your fair share so that
you can be defended right all right like
we we want there not to be a world war
that's kind of our thing in europe right
now but you're the guys who are going to
lose your homeland so maybe step up and
it's amazing when trump says fair share
comes from other places and when biden
says fair share it means that every
american should pay more money right
well only yeah rich people yeah
according to well anybody anybody who
makes more than a dollar yeah anybody
who makes any family who makes more than
exactly the price hey this is perfect
hey really quickly cnn north korea fires
two cruise missiles fifth launch this
year a headline you didn't see
under donald trump
oh yeah they show that freaky little
bella lugosi muppet
right yeah i don't remember reading a
whole lot about that during donald trump
yeah why would trump go over there to
let him know he's crazy exactly that's
how a good president you don't know
where i've been because yes
i don't know where i've been putin
by the way the chinese professor that we
showed uh yeah about biden being elected
and everyone left uh he is the vice dean
of the school of international relations
at renmin university in china renminbi
and his name is di dongsheng
ah mr dongshev
a nice cream shave also meet his uh meet
his wife madam chingpao barbara saw
[Laughter]
standing in front of those trees like
that commercial
so
you're exactly right that's a valid
point yeah putin not only respected uh
president uh president trump sorry and
doesn't have a lot of respect for
president biden a big reason was he
thought donald trump was a little bit
crazy and you know what that's a good
thing
you got to keep people on their toes
here's let's go to uh some other
international policy donald trump on
china he increased tariffs from 10
percent to 25 percent he banned chinese
uh and telecom companies like huawei
uh he rejected china's territorial
claims in the south china sea he passed
the taiwan assurance act uh 5.1 billion
dollars in arms sales to taiwan and 2020
alone he was the first president to take
a call from the taiwanese president
china of course hated that and he called
kova the china virus which let's all be
honest was a pretty pale move
oh while john cena pretended it didn't
exist exactly and all while the world
health organization acted as though
taiwan didn't exist yes
did you see the word for people who
don't remember that that's one of the
most chilling it is a skype call
uh what about taiwan oh no no can't hear
you
out
let's move on to the next question i
gotta get zoom
now let's compare this to former vice
president biden of course everyone knows
he hasn't been that big with support on
taiwan they don't feel as though they're
very secure he's also fallen lockstep
with the world health organization who
has basically refused to acknowledge
that taiwan even exists he initially
shut down the probe not sure this is
look this is what bothers me more than
any of it
shut down the probe into the covet lab
leak
yeah
why we'll just take their word why yeah
when people say donald trump uh and his
uh son's uh girlfriend kimberly gilfoy
aren't uh they're not handing over all
of their whatsapp private texts yeah but
you shut down a probe into a lab leak in
a lab where i mean they it only it had
it in the name
comedians have to point this out to you
on late night television no no no no no
no colby
come from any place other than
colvid lab trademark
yes
don't read the sign yeah don't read sign
it's uh not over we need to change
something very people get very confused
i love how they immediately pivot to we
bats what's the big deal yeah yeah yeah
what oh i forgot you never ate a bat
yeah you ever had the bed in a hoagie
room must be so nice to be so perfect
mr perfect no he's back oh no coming for
you no he's back sorry we can't all be
me mr monk you ever have a better cat a
sandwich
for me there are few things better in
life than better cat sandwich yeah you
have a bad cat it's like a oreo but with
more death right with the sadder kids a
face when you go this is your kitty
oh gosh and of course i don't shut kitty
not only did he shut down the kovid lab
lake theory
who could forget good friend of the
biden's tony babalinsky
in late 2015 i was approached by james
gillier he's still watching i had known
for many years
about joining him in a deal which he
said would involve
the chinese state-owned enterprise cfc
china
energy and what he called one of the
most prominent families in the united
states
i was informed first by gillier and then
by hunter biden
and by rob walker who was working with
the bidens that the bidens wanted to
form a new entity with cfc on may 13
2017 i received an email concerning
allocation of equity which says 10
percent held by h for the big guy
in that email there's no question that h
stands for hunter
big guy for his father
joe biden
okay really quickly this is breaking
right now on cnn pfizer begins clinical
trials for omicron specific vaccine well
then colbert's gonna need to get new
costumes i know right but everybody
needs to get a new vaccine what's the
yes exactly what's the implication there
now keep in mind you were going to be
removed from misinformation at one point
if you said that vaccine doesn't work
against omicron what's the implication
if pfizer is beginning clinical trials
frame for an omicron specific vaccine
well i would say and this is of course
hypothetical yes that perhaps the
vaccine does not protect against omicron
and also the hu it'll be human trials
that are forced on you through late
night television
well i think you hit the nail on the
head very pretty pretty much i prefer to
go with uh
clear i like clear
no you can use it if you get the omicron
vaccine and whatever other vaccine is
necessary you know
no it's fine it's a vaccine where you
still get the virus it makes perfect
sense yes it's a vaccine where you still
get the virus you can still transmit the
virus and you know um
that's why we all have polio boy i i
tell you what whoever is the salesman
for these vaccines at this point yeah
i mean he deserves just all the money
salesman of the year well it's joe
that's gotta be incredibly difficult
joe biden they just trot him back out
he's like uh he goes out he's like okay
all right yeah by the way if uh you get
this vaccine we can reopen the economy
because the vaccine you know it
immunizes you and what they just uh okay
they just change the definition of
immunization okay so look if you get the
vaccine it'll protect against and it
doesn't all right not anymore you get
the vaccine you can still get it and you
can can they transmit it
yeah yeah they can you can still
transmit it but you're not going to end
up in a
hospital or what with the what's the
omicron there's a okay look the rate of
getting into the hospital or death with
the vaccine or without it is about the
same and you can both but uh you know
what
i mean can i just i quit
wait will vaccinated celebrities be
hospitalized with it but still be on a
camera telling you to get the vaccine
well
yeah yeah yeah yeah is it possible that
we'd have like a record number of fit
soccer players around the world just
dropping in matches uh hold on how does
the vaccine affect gay athletes
we think it's more so the aids it's oh
okay well it's a different different
thing you rang
reliable sources all right i'm more
worried about the effect it might be
having on stand-up comedians
[Laughter]
that's the real
tragedy here let's go let's contrast now
uh
president trump with former vice
president joe biden on north korea
because we just talked about missiles
being launched like it's the 4th of july
this year uh there was a nuclear and
long-range missile moratorium when
donald trump was president in 2018 if
you guys don't remember trump met with
kim jong-un in singapore the first
meeting ever between the united states
and uh the north korean leader um
look a lot of people gave him crap just
to be clear donald trump they were
saying oh he's being he's being too nice
to him look he's getting buddy buddy he
called him little rocket man just to be
clear yes
north korea returned the remains of
fallen us soldiers which was a big deal
now here's the thing in 2019 he became
the first sitting president ever to
enter north korea people freaked now by
the way where's code pink
when when we had president trump right
he was trying to avoid any kind of war
conflict with north korea remember code
pink remember we no war no sending our
people to war you will never find
in recent possibly all of american
history a more anti-war president here's
the thing you can only
you can only negotiate from that
position
if you are willing
to go to war at the end of it but you
have to
exhaust all other possibilities what did
donald trump do donald trump this is
the same criticism that's been um you
know uh uh lobbed against him and it's
true is well donald trump is good to you
you're his best friend until you uh you
know you insult him and then all of a
sudden you're his worst enemy and that's
true and i think that's childish however
it was the same thing with internet
international negotiations with kim
jong-un he would be nice he would want
to keep it peaceful so that we could
have peaceful negotiations and if he
didn't get what he wanted he had an iron
rod and he wasn't afraid to use it and
you can see the behavior from foreign
leaders we can't just place emphasis on
words though i would say the words
coming out of this administration are
pretty bad actions matter and not only
actions of our sitting leaders but the
actions of the leaders who follow them
yeah so well it was helpful to have a
businessman somebody who understood that
when you're negotiating it's best to do
it from a position of strength right and
right now we're doing it from a position
of weakness we're apologizing for
everything and saying i don't know maybe
you guys know better than we do yeah
right if you're going to go and
negotiate in these situations especially
with mad men around the world
in isolation hasn't worked you have to
go over and be like look we can be
friends right we can be enemies trust me
you want us to be friends how do you
trust a presidency where your first move
is to sign everything back over to the
people right that way that have an issue
with it it makes literally the pipeline
that's going through your country but
put the one in place that's going
through the person who's just everything
that was done that seemed to be correct
which no one cares about it's all that
guy was mean yeah exactly and he could
be and orange yep but who gives like no
exactly you're exactly it's just it i
hate or the fact that he went golfing
while he wasn't taking a salary
meanwhile this guy's taking it he took
it and he donated it to another
department right he donated in one year
as president more than former vice
president biden has his entire life he's
the least charitable politician who
existed well yeah and on top of it there
they complain about how he would you
know any vacation trump took which was
very little other than golfing right
look at how many vacations biden has
taken that doesn't even count when he's
just sleeping afternoon naps well i mean
it's hard the days they run together
yeah that is true why am i still alive
oh god
seriously what is he awake for a day 43
minutes i can't believe it's still today
so here's the thing donald trump let's
use this here's the difference okay
donald trump is a president who you
didn't want to count to three
biden's counted to three many times and
you know that it has no teeth okay
donald trump very nice
at first and then you knew where he had
his limit former vice president by any
postures i won't meet with these leaders
these p these people are tyrants doesn't
meet with them but then doesn't actually
do something when they act up now we
don't necessarily know what donald trump
would have done if they acted up because
they didn't under his watch keep in mind
trump left no doubt as to who was in
charge when he met with uh kim jong
lugosi
there he is
getting a good picture everybody so we
look nice and handsome
and here's the thing guys here's the
thing have you seen him now fat shaming
works look he inspires people to become
better i love nice and thin
it looks over at him
he points across the table that one was
that one wasn't for me that wasn't for
me
i don't think that one hurt
joe biden is actually cartman's mom
right like everybody just abuses them
and she tries to threaten but she just
gives them everything exactly she
doesn't do anything
and by the way here's what also
here's what also matters is um you know
he was the first president to step foot
in north korea donald trump went over
and he had terms
and they were non-negotiable if north
korea didn't denuclearize no deal and he
left no deal just to be clear he left no
deal so he was nice up until the all
right no deal look a little racket man
look at little rocket bend with his fat
baby face
i loved you on orange is the new black
[Laughter]
yeah he really
he loves he lost weight because trump
that's exactly i guarantee you that's
what it is can you imagine doing that to
a dictator and then calling that a bad
president can you imagine being the
interpreter who had to break it to him
yeah well out with it uh mr deleter uh
uh uh i'm here with your interpretation
of a transcript with a donald trump
uh-huh will he say i'm supreme uh
uh not not exactly uh
uh
what do you say that i have giant pecker
no um um
all right well you're gonna die yes it's
the kill the messenger meeting
i haven't written in my uh day planner
kill messenger meeting what did you want
to say
oh he said your dick is huge
oh so big freeze don't hurt my face so
scary
[Laughter]
he says your face looks good
yeah you say your face look good not
like a half a moon on a predominant zone
look great good face
very youthful handsome
let's compare it to buying with north
korea okay well you just saw the high
top fade
i love it you just you just saw it right
now they're launching more missiles yeah
is that their fifth test that we just
saw live right now this year or in a
year i can't remember this year ah who
cares the point is it's more yeah
biden won't meet with kim jong-un oh
that's wonderful
oh oh no you want to meet with me oh
though he hit me with hurt i was so
looking forward to sitting there eating
a meeting is anything scarier than the
idea of practice missiles they're still
missiles yes
that's called a warm-up yeah like what
the messenger don't worry just a
practice stabbing
oh thank you supreme leader
oh what do you say now oh give me such a
great honor to be practicing sad
tell kids i love them practice or shoot
your family with bags on their head yeah
practice make you look like a mile
rooker and go driving this convertible
on crowded freeway
now uh let's look at trump in the middle
east kind of a big one signed four major
peace deals between israel and arab
states unprecedented [ __ ] moved the
embassy to jerusalem he killed solomani
and he killed uh a boo i can't look
al-baghdaddy i'm not gonna full name
he was the guy who was just a torso left
that was like steaming pretty much i'll
beg who's your daddy let's listen to
donald trump describe it exactly again
guy who didn't want war a guy who said
that it was a mistake to go into the
middle east but then
scorched earth here he is tonight was a
great night for the united states
and for the world
a brutal killer
one who has caused so much hardship and
death
has violently been eliminated
he will never again harm another
innocent man woman or child
he died like a dog
he died like a coward
the world is now a much safer place
he was a sick
and depraved
man
and now he's gone
that daddy was
vicious he was crazy and violent
and he died in a vicious and violent way
as a coward running and crying did i
mention that i had the look excuse me i
had the body transported here because i
needed a place to put my [ __ ]
to take my [ __ ]
it was back daddy's corpse that's what i
did i took it
the fact that he's not dressed like
josie wales
i love how he's like he's like we didn't
just kill somebody we violently
we should be doing a cigar we could have
eliminated him non-violently but i said
no i want tears i want him to be like a
and not just like a dog with the cage
and the fleas like fauci i mean i want
him killed
like a street dog in afghanistan let's
be clear now let's compare that
and oh by the way he destroyed isis
let's compare that to uh former
president of course during the tenure of
former vice president joe biden his
words
was moving too slowly
but the fall of ramadi has galvanized
the iraqi government
so with the additional steps i ordered
last month we're speeding up training of
isil forces including volunteers from
sunni tribes in anbar province remember
when they still were trying to make isil
a thing yeah exactly
it's isis isil i i don't know lots of
letters isil sounded better yeah yeah
now
also when we look at uh the
international policy what did joe biden
well he caused a crisis in afghanistan
we all know that he allowed the taliban
to take over he left them weapons and
helicopters well and pallets of cash
yeah well that's you know it's i mean
it's okay it's just our tax money it's
just pallets
every time you hit a pothole just
remember there's pallets of catch in
afghanistan
and by the you don't have to take my
word for it do you know how we know they
didn't have helicopters until biden
screwed up just watch the first flights
like am i doing it
like the guy with a rocket launcher in
the gym yeah at the embassy just
blackhawk down after blackhawk
don't worry i'm getting the hang of it
these are hard i didn't know i thought
it was more like a you know but it's
more of a gyroscope really oh well let
me uh just make the most of it find the
building
i think biden was just like you know
what we should do we should pull out
right now why it's just the worst time
yes yes i think that's the best time to
pull out is when we shouldn't nothing
else i have bad instincts
well people were just wanting to get on
the plane like toucan salmon
military planes are real popular they're
hanging on the sides as they take off
that's beautiful oh he's flying come on
look oh he got the plane flying they got
the people flying from the plane wow
it's too flying come on beautiful birds
so here's let's let's compare also here
a little closer to him trump on mexico
what did he do he threatened to impose a
tariff to make them stop sending their
immigrants over uh the remaining mexico
policy which uh biden reinstated donald
uh anyway the whole thing is you can
just look at you can look at barack
obama and then you can look at the
reversals with donald trump and then he
can look at where we're headed again
with former vice president joe biden in
2017 trump had under 303 000 border
crossings that was the lowest since
1971. let's compare the results with
former vice president joe biden record
high of 122 000 unaccompanied kids in
custody there was a record high 1.7
million border apprehensions in 2021 and
not only that it's this these are the
results and you say okay well hold on a
second maybe you know the road to hell
paved with good and good intentions
right well let's listen to president uh
kamala harris uh say that mass amnesty
is expected
as early as now
a year ago you took office and you
outlined a series of bold
steps on
immigration reform so can you tell us
whether you've accomplished some of
those administration's goals and where
do you see yourself this year going
forward with immigration what are your
expectations so it was one of the first
things we did as an administration which
is to send a bill up to congress for
immigration reform for pathway to
citizenship we feel very strongly about
this
why hmm
i like the mask yeah well she's going
color coordinated you know what that
does it basically says open season again
all you got to do is get here if you get
here we're going to do amnesty no biggie
and here's the thing there's there's
nefarious activity right you can look at
malicious intent and when i say
malicious let me just be clear i mean
malicious intent for you the american
taxpayer and when i say american
taxpayer i also mean naturalized
citizens i also mean
legal immigrants just to be clear yeah
my mom is one of them okay malicious
intent for you you're already here they
don't need to buy your votes and then
there's just you know unintended
consequences for example i don't think
they meant to put a record number of
children in cages this is probably the
most important moment that the media
wishes they could sweep under the rug
from the presidential debates about
those cages that were broadcast across
all of legitimate media uh as though
they were created under president donald
trump and president donald trump just
like in dealing with uh a foreign
minister
made sure that he corrected the record
who built the cages let's talk about who
built the cages one question who built
the cages i'd love you to ask him that
who built the cages let me ask him who
built the cages who built the cage let
me ask about your immigration who built
the cages let's talk about
so look
when here's what it comes down to when
the world respects and fears the united
states okay uh the world is better off
look you can either have the united the
united states in control have them be in
a position of power and i don't mean
policing the rest of the world but we
are the world's greatest superpower or
that void can be filled by someone else
you've seen this throughout history
usually the void is filled by someone
who's more bloodthirsty who's more power
hungry also this is important to note
look people want to say that the left is
more compassionate but oh the in other
words when i was a young i think this
was a churchill quote right if you're
young and you're not a liberal you have
no heart if you're old and you're not
conservative you have no brain
i disagree
i disagree maybe at one time when the
united states was
newer and this was an experiment and
free enterprise was something that
hadn't really been tried before however
when you look at the results and again
all references available at
earthquaker.com every single reference
i've given you you can click the link in
the description go to
lotteworthcrowder.com we make them
publicly available to you today's
references could be as long as a novel
you're probably looking at hundreds of
pages to read just to be clear and i
hope that you spend some time with them
the results speak for themselves and i
think you're lying to yourself
you're lying to yourself and more
importantly the people at the top who
have access to these results just like
president obama never believed that
women made 77 cents on the dollar
because he has access to bing the people
in positions of power know that
inflation is bad the people in positions
of power the gensakes of the world the
former vice president biden of the world
the kamala harris they know that no new
jobs have been added since 2019 and they
know that their immigration policies
have been catastrophic for the united
states and
that it is the kind of policies that
built the cages let's contrast that
what's more empathetic
what's more humanitarian
to build a wall
so that you don't have to put people in
cages or to have a policy
that requires cages that's what i i
think it's more empathetic i think it's
more compassionate to build walls walls
not cages how about that walls not cages
we went cages okay eight years wall
four years and now we're back to cages
you know what let's put that at
crowdershop.com we're gonna make a shirt
walls not cages youtube if you don't
like this i don't care everyone else you
can leave a comment smash that like
button thank you rumble we're gonna go
play marvelous movie titles on mug club
youtube piss off i'm matt
[Music]
you